that's why if it was anybody else like
oh this is garbage but when it's Connor
there's they can't do anything though
there's no repercussions this guy
clearly does whatever he wants so
usually like hey man let's be the first
announce he's like say less posted it's
weirdos on Fight Pass it makes sense
that they're doing it uh I like to think
it's gonna happen it has to be Chandler
my initial reaction was like no but this
year December I think so that was the
plan right
and he does get his way so
there's nobody more powerful in the UFC
if that's what he wants to do and when
he came out with the comments with those
Voice Notes too he's the only guy can
move make moves like this yeah when he
says jump the UFC says how high sir and
we all want to watch it so I don't
testing
one leg dude get him in there sign me up
take my money